okay
so welcome back everybody to uh
705. i know this has been a
really challenging semester for all of
us i want to
particularly acknowledge for the seniors
out there the the tragedy of missing the
end of your senior year
hopefully us mit can somehow make it
up to you i can say for my part we will
do our best to
teach you biochemistry remotely and just
as a couple
logistics a reminder i'm matt
vanderheiden i'm going to be
covering the remaining part
of of 705 for the rest of the semester
we get to focus on biochemistry of
metabolism we're going to learn what
metabolism
is why it's important and
basically this is can be quite a
polarizing topic
in my experience people tend to really
love or really hate metabolism
it's interesting because there are some
people out there who pretend to hate it
but
actually deep down really love it
hopefully i will
inspire you over the rest of the
semester to
at least have some appreciation for why
metabolism is important
and regardless for those of you who want
to go to med school this is a favorite
topic of
mcat exams and also you will see that it
will come up
in many different areas of biology
regardless of whether you go to med
school or not so if you do anything
further in biology hopefully you'll find
this material
somewhat useful okay so getting into
what metabolism is so i think it's good
to start with a textbook definition of
metabolism
and so metabolism is the chemical
reactions
that all cells
and organisms
use to do two things
one extract energy
from the environment
and two
synthesize
the macromolecules
that make up all life
so really what metabolism is then is the
chemistry that
makes life possible and so understanding
metabolism
is really something that will help you
better understand your food
there's lots of material out there in
the popular press about what's healthy
and what's not
at least this will allow you to form
some of your own opinions about those
claims
and how they relate to what really goes
on in our cells and bodies
there's lots of implications for
medicine very relevant to
agriculture the energy sector biofuels
come from
and so metabolism really matters to
tackle many of the challenges
that face us in society now as a topic
this can be very daunting
as shown here on this image we have
um hundreds this is a typical oops
this is a typical metabolic pathway
chart
that is hanging in the walls of my
office many other
laboratories and academic places around
the world
if you look at this chart it's filled
with hundreds of enzymes
complex pathways our goal here is not to
memorize this chart you can always look
up details of any pathway or reaction
that you want
the goal here really is to see beyond
this complexity
i want you to appreciate why metabolism
works the way it does
why this chart is organized as it is
because what we will find is that this
chart is really
variations on relatively few reactions
it basically is life repurposing
similar chemistry to do many different
things i think there is a beauty in how
life can use these reactions to get such
a diversity of macromolecules
and enable cells to solve all kinds of
different problems
you'll see that all of the pathways
really follow common principles these
are shared across
all species and all forms of life and so
at the chemical level all life is really
related and this is why it's so
relevant to understanding many of the
challenges in
medicine understanding ecology evolution
and for you mit students you'll see it's
also very critical
for using engineering approaches based
on biology to solve various problems
in the world okay so now let's
start getting into this a bit more now
the first topic that we're going to
cover over the next several lectures
really relates to coming back to sugars
and carbohydrates which i
talked about and introduced in my
previous lecture
and we're going to do this because
sugars and carbohydrates are key energy
transduction molecules and cells
and it really facilitates a discussion
of the principles for how metabolism
works
now our goal here isn't to memorize
pathways we could
you know read about the glycolytic
pathway
in a couple in an hour or i could draw
it up here in a very short period of
time many of you have probably already
done this
in high school our goal is instead to
understand this pathway at a deeper
level really see
why the breakdown of sugars works the
way it does
how cells use this to release energy and
how that can be used to support other
cell functions
and so before we get to that i want to
start by introducing just a couple
high-level concepts about metabolism
and so really based on our definition
before
metabolism is really about two things
it's about making stuff
and we have a fancy term for that that
is called
anabolism
it's about breaking stuff down
and the term for that is called
catabolism
and anabolism building stuff that is
producing biomass
growing all of the material that's out
there
anabolic steroids help you grow this is
anabolism to build stuff
that is one side of metabolism the other
side is breaking stuff down catabolism
that is
breaking down our food eating food
digesting our food as a way to get
energy
now of course to reproduce life has to
build more cells you need more stuff
you can't create something from nothing
and so that requires energy input
anabolism typically requires energy
input
whereas that energy has to come from
somewhere
and that's where catabolism comes from
we have to break down
food and ultimately that is catabolism
is the source for biological energy for
many different um systems now
some of this is actually somewhat
intuitive we all learned as little kids
that we need to eat food if we're gonna
grow up and be
big and strong you also know that if
you're gonna run a race you gotta
eat a bunch of food you need that energy
to fuel your activity
but maybe what's less intuitive to many
of you is we also need energy to sustain
life
even if we're doing absolutely nothing
okay adults
sit on the couch all day hopefully
they're not growing
but they'll still starve if they don't
constantly eat some food
even if they're inactive and so why is
that the case
well hopefully some of you recall the
second law of thermodynamics
so what is the second law of
thermodynamics it's
in effect the entropy
of the universe is
increasing okay
that life care the universe continually
tends towards
disorder life is exactly the opposite of
this
life is actually maintaining extreme
order
in the face of the second law and so all
life must constantly battle
entropy and many have described life at
the very highest level
as being a really the ability to main
order to fight entropy
which of course requires constant energy
input
and metabolism is the process that all
cells use to do this
now for humans i think we all know we
need to eat and breathe in order to
stay alive for you future mds out there
what happens if your heart stops or you
start stop breathing
well of course you die in a matter of
several minutes
why is that well that's because every
cell in your body
has to do constant catabolism in order
to derive energy
in order to remain viable this means
they need
constant food and particularly oxygen
delivery and if you don't get those
things metabolism can no longer work
and the cells die and so
energy is sort of this mystical com
concept that we like to talk about and
so
before we delve a little bit deeper into
what i mean by biological energy
what it is why we have to constantly do
catabolism to maintain it
i want to go back and say just a little
bit more about carbohydrates and finish
our discussion there
and talk about carbohydrates and sugar
polymers polysaccharides
because this has some additional
properties i didn't have time to cover
in my prior lecture
that is important to understand how it
allows these molecules to store
energy in a very efficient way and it'll
also enable us to talk a little bit
about how carbohydrates can also be used
as structural molecules for lots of
different
organisms all right so a little
diversion
to discuss carbohydrates and
polysaccharides
and so if you recall from my prior
lecture sugars that are greater than
four to five carbons
can exist either in open chain or
ring forms okay furanose or pyranose
rings
i'll just remind you by redrawing up
here
glucose
so this is d glucose
drawn in the open chain form remember
this can
form a ring
okay so it's a reminder carbon one
two three four five
six if we have this hydroxyl group from
carbon five form a hemiacetal bond with
the
aldehyde at carbon one you get this
ring structure this would be alpha
or beta depending on whether the
hydroxyl group here at carbon one
is pointing up or pointing down
d glucose
so this is review of what we already
talked about last time
now what i want to talk about is that if
we form
a disaccharide or a polysaccharide that
is begin to make sugar bonds
and if we do that in a way that ties up
this hemiacetal or hemiketal bond
this then prevents the ring from opening
and gaining access to
that carbonyl that aldehyde carbonyl as
this moves between the open chain
and the ring form and so a good example
of this is the disaccharide
sucrose so sucrose is a disaccharide
of glucose plus
galactose
okay and here is what this disaccharide
looks like
okay so you have here glucose
in the um alpha d pyranose form
here's fructose in the beta because the
oh group is pointing out
fructo furanos form and so the formal
name
for this molecule sucrose would be alpha
d gluco
pirano seal
one two because we're going from
carbon one of glucose to carbon
two there's one two three
four five six of
fructose
beta d
fructo
firanos sucrose or alpha d gluco
pyranoseal one two beta d
fructo furanos okay
so this disaccharide forms a bond
between carbon one and carbon two that
would be the
aldehyde in glucose or the ketone
tied up in the hemiacetal or the hemi
ketal bond
of these two molecules and so there's no
way that either of these sugars can
access
the open chain form without breaking
this
oak like acidic bond and that's one
reason why sucrose is a very good
storage molecule for
carbohydrates because without breaking
that bond you prevent
access to gaining these reactive
aldehyde or ketone bonds
that could react with some other
molecule
in the cell now i mentioned this because
whether or not a particular sugar
is enabled to get access to this
reactive
aldehyde or ketone really forms the
basis
for a classic sugar detection lab test
and this is relevant to discuss this lab
test because it explains some
nomenclature that is still used and in
fact we will continue
to use a bit as we discuss some aspects
of sugar metabolism
so what this test is is basically is
that
if you heat the sugar with
copper okay which is blue
and that copper can gain access to a
free carbonyl that is if the sugar can
access
the open chain form to expose the
aldehyde or
keystone that copper can then become
reduced to copper plus that changes the
color
from blue to red and so if you
reduce the copper you oxidize
the bond there and this test turns
positive
if there is a reducing sugar
is what it's called
so a sugar that reduces the copper
from the blue two plus state to the red
plus state
is a positive test and so basically a
reducing
sugar is any sugar
with an ability
to access
open chain form
because that will provide the free
aldehyde or
ketone to reduce the copper
in this test so this term reducing sugar
obviously applies to
all monosaccharides because every single
one of them has an aldehyde or a ketone
and can
access the open chain form but it'll
only apply to
some disaccharides or polysaccharides
so look come back to sucrose up there so
is sucrose or reducing sugar
no it's not because there is no way that
you can access
a free aldehyde or ketone in
sucrose because it's tied up in that oak
like acidic bond
between carbon one of glucose and carbon
two of
fructose and so you need to break that
bond to give the monosaccharide subunits
in order to access
the open chain form however let's give
an example of a disaccharide that
can be a reducing that is a reducing
sugar
and that's the disaccharide maltose so
maltose
is basically two glucose molecules
and those two glucose molecules
are like this
okay so this has a o glycosidic bond
between
carbon one of this glucose and carbon
four
of that glucose and so formally this
would be
alpha d gluco
puranoseal
1 4 alpha
or beta pointing down
alpha pointing up as beta d gluco
pyranose so maltose
or alpha-d glucopranosyl one for alpha
or beta
glucopuranos is a reducing sugar
because this sugar could access the open
chain form you
could open up this carbonyl and expose
the free aldehyde at position one
now we could also refer to this sugar as
having two different ends we can refer
to this
end as being the non-reducing end
and this end as being the
reducing end because of course this
bond this aldehyde on the first
glucose is tied up in this o glycosidic
bond
whereas the one on this one is not so
this end is non-reducing
and this end is reducing
now this becomes much more relevant if
we start talking about
polymers and so what starch
is so starch what potatoes
are made out of is basically a polymer
of maltose
of maltose molecules so basically or
glucose with
1-4 linkages
uh
okay so i could draw that end the
reducing
end of the polymer
in the alpha or beta but
this here being the non-reducing end
every other subunit is tied up in this
one for
o glycosidic bond and so starch is
really a polymer
of glucose molecules with bonds between
the one and the four position of each
subunit now we will see later
that we build and break down starch
polymers from
only one end from the non-reducing end
and so having these terms reducing and
non-reducing
provides a term to specify different
ends of a polymer
reducing and non-reducing ends turns out
also be important for
naming conventions for disaccharides or
polysaccharides
and this becomes relevant if we consider
the disaccharide lactose
so lactose is also a polymer
of glucose plus galactose
except this polymer of glucose galactose
unlike sucrose is different because it
has
a different linkage between
the glucose sorry glucose
i apologize
sucrose is a disaccharide of
glucose plus fructose
fructose i wrote the name correctly but
lactose
is a disaccharide between glucose and
galactose
and so i'll draw it here
do
okay so this is lactose
this is galactose here on the
non-reducing end
so the formal name for this would be
beta
because there's a beta linkage here
between carbon
1 and carbon carbon one of this
galactose and carbon four
of this glucose so b beta d
galacto
piranha seal
1 4 this is glucose
in the alpha or beta
d
glucose
pyranose lactose or beta d galacto
pyranosel14
alpha or beta depending if i drew down
alpha of beta
d glucopyranose now
this also has
non-reducing
and reducing
ends and by convention you would name
the sugar
from the non-reducing end to the
reducing end hence i put
galacto pyranoseal one for alpha d-gluco
pyranose um named them in
that order now you'll note
that lactose unlike starch
unlike maltose unlike sucrose
links these disaccharides with a beta
linkage
between this sugar and that sugar where
the other ones had
alpha linkages and structurally this is
very different and i just want to point
that out
so this here is basically um
alpha d-gluco pyranose and so
alpha this would be this is carbon one
this is the hydroxyl pointing down
that's why it's alpha if i make an o
glycosidic bond to another sugar
you can see that it points and creates
this kinked structure
now if i were to make this beta this
hydroxyl rather than being here
would be at this position on carbon one
you can see that that now creates a very
different
very different geometry now you have a
flat molecule
as opposed to a kinked molecule
now this has consequences of course for
the enzymes that break down these sugars
obviously it's going to be a very
different enzyme
that breaks a bond in this orientation
versus a bond in that orientation
this has
basically implications for what enzymes
we have and so
lactose of course is milk sugar
all mammals make milk so make
lactose and break it down when we're
babies um
but most mammals tend to lose expression
of the enzyme lactase that's able to
break this
one for beta linkage
um as we age and this is basically what
accounts for
lactose intolerance now
if you think about it in the world much
of the
world has issues with varying degrees of
lactose intolerance in adulthood the
exception to this is often people of
european ancestry
why is this well europeans historically
drank milk well into adulthood
and so this selected for continuous
lactose or lactase the enzyme that would
break that beta 1 4 linkage
expression as um people move into
adulthood
and so it's an example of how cultural
um things drinking milk into adult
adulthood
really affected evolution um
such that that subpopulation of people
people with that genetics to increase
lacto lactase expression
um um don't become lactose intolerant um
as they age now this alpha versus
beta linkage that is whether or not you
have this
more kinked versus more flat structure
also has
a major effect on the structure
of a polymer as well and so
if we look here at this starch polymer
it's basically
this series of glucose molecules stuck
together
with alpha one four linkages so that's
going to create
a kinked structure this is best shown
here on this slide so you can see this
kink structure and so when you build
this polymer
you're going to end up more with this
helical structure
in 3d space that's a very efficient way
to store
glucose monomers in much less space than
you would otherwise get
with beta linkages
now it turns out that nature takes us a
step further
and in addition to just having this
starch polymer
it turns out sometimes you can add
branches to the starch polymer
to further increase the efficiency of
energy storage
okay so if you have here a
starch polymer so i just draw here a
couple subunits
okay so this here is a starch polymer
glucose polymer with alpha 1 4
linkages that i can put an additional
branch on this by
adding a linkage up here on the top
with an alpha one
six linkage so the one position of here
to the
sixth position of here which has the
effect
of creating branches
on this long polymer such that
you have a single
reducing n
and lots
of non-reducing
ends each of these non-reducing
ends has a polymer of alpha 1 4
linkages that would be stuck to the main
chain polymer
via this alpha 1 6 linkage
and this has a couple implications for
storage the first is by only having one
reducing end it reduces maximally the
exposure to a free aldehyde and so that
makes it
a good storage sugar and also as we will
see
we're going to break down these
sugar polymers biologically from the
non-reducing
ends and so there's and build from those
ends and so there's
lots of hooks or lots of places to
either add or remove
sugars from which allows you to access
um carbohydrates quickly as needed
that's shown nicely here on this slide
better than i can draw it so up here you
have your
non-reducing end across a polymer so
this here would be starch with the
alpha 1 4 linkages on the polymer or
reducing end on one side non-reducing
end on the other
you can then add branch points to that
by making an oak like acidic bond
between
carbon one down to carbon six creating a
branch and so you can see this helical
branch structure will then form
that is both very efficient to pack lots
of glucose into one place
and give lots of non-reducing ends
with which to build and remove sugars
from
for biology to either store or quickly
access sugar molecules as needed
now in plants
of course potatoes use starch in a
straight chain
we know that however plants also use
this
branched structure this is a molecule
called amylopectin
amylopectin is better known in the food
industry is sure
gel it's the material that allows you to
make
jelly it's the gelling agent and jelly
and
effectively this has every
every 24 to 30 units
there would be a branch with one of
these alpha 1 6 linkages
to give you this multi-branch structure
now
animals don't make starch animals don't
make amylopectin
but amyl animals make another molecule
called
glycogen glycogen
also a sugar polymer exactly like
amylopectin alpha 1 4 linkages with
these alpha 1
6 to create branch points just like
amylopectin
except glycogen has even more branches
with a branch every 8
to 12 glucose
units and so this is a very complex
structure for both plants and animals
to quickly store and quickly release
glucose molecules
when they're needed now this
is in contrast to a glucose
polymer that can be done that has a very
different 3d structure so what if we
take
starch and rather than have these alpha
1 4 linkages but instead replace these
with beta 1 4
linkages okay so now
beta linkages looks simple enough but
this
changing the geometry from the alpha to
the beta bond
removes the kink now it's much more of a
flat structure
turns out this is here's a
shown on an image here so here's a beta
linkage and so now you have this flat
structure
this is the same polymer as starch
chemically but has a different linkage
the beta 1 4 linkage
and that polymer with the
beta 1 4 linkage
is cellulose and cellulose is of course
what
wood is made out of and so wood in
potatoes cellulose and starch
exactly the same polymer same number of
calories if you could access the glucose
units
but the alpha and beta bonds make them
very different obviously
wood and cellulose is a very good
structural
polymer for plants we build houses out
of it
we don't build houses out of potatoes
but we eat a lot of potatoes so
equally good molecule for plants to
store
lots of food for energy turns out wood
is a great source of energy
too you just need to have an enzyme that
can break the beta 1
4 bond termites have symbiotic microbes
that allow them to do this and this is
why termites can
eat wood a lot of energy tied up in wood
now we lack the time to go into the
details about how this relates to
other structural carbohydrates but in
general structural carbohydrate or
carbohydrate-like molecules
form polymers of sugar or related
molecules
also with these beta linkages and a good
example is chitin so the material in
insect shells
is basically a sugar-like molecule
that's a polymer with a
beta linkage in it same thing of
cartilage in
humans and animals and you can look up
the details of what these things look
like
of course if you're interested chitin
and
and cartilage aren't made of true
polysaccharide polymers but they're very
related to polysaccharides
and they really illustrate how nature
can take carbohydrate chemistry
and repurpose it to basically act as an
energy source but also
build all kinds of structural molecules
that are really
useful in biology okay
all right now i want to go back to
here's ways that one can store
and use carbohydrates in interesting
ways but now i want to come back to them
as energy sources and assuming you can
access the glucose and
whatever polymer it's present in how can
you
actually metabolize it to provide energy
in a way that
sustains life and this means we're going
to turn to
another topic a topic that's typically
referred to
as bioenergetics
bioenergetics which is really the
discussion of how
energy is transduced in biological
systems i'm going to introduce this
topic today we're going to revisit it
throughout the course but it's really
important to ask this question we really
want to
consider what do we mean when we say
biological energy what is biological
energy
well someone probably made you memorize
in high school and often you're thinking
oh it's
just atp and certainly atp
adenosine triphosphate is
a very important molecule for biological
energy transduction but i want to
actually explore
why atp is actually useful
and if atp is energy why don't we just
eat all kinds of atp
i can say for a fact that absolutely
none of you had atp today for breakfast
no one sells atp as an energy booster
and so if atp is such a great energy
source why don't we just
eat it and to really understand atp
how it works what biological energy
really
is we really need to revisit some very
basic topics in
thermodynamics now thermodynamics
strikes fear into the hearts of
students everywhere you can get details
of thermodynamics and the theory
around these things and other courses
that's not really what we're going
to try to accomplish here in 705
our goal here is really a practical
understanding of how thermodynamics
applies to biology
and metabolism and we need to go into
this because it's key to understanding
why we store energy go through all this
trouble to store energy is these
carbohydrate polymers to begin with why
we eat potatoes and not
atp as well as why atp
is actually useful to cells and so
let's take a step back and just think
about it let's think about wood i just
told you
wood is a polymer of glucose molecules
with beta
1 4 linkages how can we
just as forget as organisms as
cells but how can you release energy
from wood to do other kinds of work well
we can burn it and so what's the
chemistry of burning wood well
it's a carbohydrate polymer so it has
this
cn h2n um
uh formula if we combine
that carbohydrate with oxygen it
releases
co2 in water plus
some light plus heat
this light and heat is
energy we can use it
to do work boil water turn a turbine
make electricity
whatever use the
warm ourselves by the fire give
ourselves um
use the light to do some other things
okay
and so this burning of wood is certainly
release of energy now we lack the
enzymes
to do this reaction and wood because we
can't break that beta 1
4 linkage but we certainly can break
that
alpha 1 4 linkage in starch from
potatoes
and we use the exact same chemistry
to burn that glucose and release
energy except the difference is is that
if i burn wood i do this
all in one step but life is a much
better engineer than that it basically
rather than releasing all of that energy
in one step
it really releases it step wise in a
manner
that's actually useful to cells but it's
exactly the same release of energy
and so what life is
or extracting biological energy is
is it's really the ability to do
stepwise
oxidation
of glucose or other carbon i'll write
glucose for now
to get
energy okay so we burn wood
that's favorable it releases energy
if we do stepwise oxidation we also
can release energy as well same reaction
also releases energy how much energy do
we get from
releasing us burning glucose as you do
when burning it
in a fire well it has to be exactly the
same amount
because it's exactly the same reaction
so we burn wood
we get light and heat cells burn glucose
it releases the exact same amount of
energy it just does so in a way that
allows the cells to do biologically
useful things
what are those well it could be heat all
of us maintain temperature so heat is
a conversion of energy that of course is
useful to
biology but it can do other things too
it can allow cells to move it can allow
them to do
any reaction to fight that entropy that
allows life
to exist and so
all things including ourselves have to
follow
the same laws of thermodynamics okay
life is not special in that regard
and so burning wood is favorable because
it
increases the entropy of the universe
right you're breaking up this polymer
into a bunch of monomers that's going to
be spontaneous
that is in accordance with the second
law
of thermodynamics
if cells burn it as well but
remember the second law says that net
entropy of the use
of the universe must always increase and
so if we're going to do something that's
not energetically favorable
like build a glucose polymer we
obviously have to put energy into it
okay
and to do so the energy that's released
must be
greater than the energy that we actually
store
and so this is actually a really key
point because
anything that we do that requires
energy input for a cell to carry out
that process
requires a source of energy release
somewhere else that is equivalent or
greater than what is actually put in
and so cells need energy because they do
lots of thermodynamically unfavorable
things
fighting that entropy of the universe
and all of those processes must come
from the release of energy elsewhere
like
the burning of carbohydrate
and so that constant energy input
is at the very highest level why we need
to do
constant metabolism in order to maintain
order
and survive as organisms now this of
course comes from
things like burning of of uh
of carbohydrate but of course that
carbohydrate has to come from somewhere
and so ultimately you have to have an
external source
that external source is of course the
sun photosynthetic organisms can use
light energy from the sun to do exactly
these same things
build those excess polymers and it's why
we as
animals or anything that eats other
animals as a way to live
is ultimately depending on eating
photosynthetic organisms because
photosynthetic organisms
do this by harvesting energy
of the sun now that's all very high
level
but i want to come back to the specifics
of metabolism ultimately and understand
those
as how they relate to enzymes reactions
and pathways that is how do you get
that complex series of reactions that
make life possible
and ultimately still be guided by these
exact
same principles in other words how do we
couple the energy releasing
reactions like burning glucose
in a way that obeys the laws of
thermodynamics and operates under
biologically acceptable conditions
in order to do things that are
biologically unfavorable that's really
what bioenergetics
is and so the next thing we want to
consider then if we want to understand
this
is really let's ask the question what
determines
if a specific
reaction occurs
that is what determines if something
like burning wood
actually spontaneously if you light wood
on fire it will burn
it does so every single time everyone
has had that experience
but no one has ever seen co2 and water
spontaneously come together and form a
tree
that doesn't happen so what determines
whether
you burn wood and that is favorable
versus why it is that co2 and water
don't come together and spontaneously
form
a tree do not say or do not think
that this is determined entirely by
enzymes
enzymes are catalysts enzymes are the
spark that makes the burning of wood
possible but remember enzymes cannot
change
thermodynamics enzymes only change the
rate at which a reaction happens
it does not change the equilibrium that
tree
wants to if given the catalyst
forms co2 in water that reaction is
spontaneous because it is
thermodynamically favorable
that tree will not take co2 and water
and spontaneously reform a tree
and there's no amount of enzyme that
will make that happen
all by itself and so remember that if
you have any reaction
between a and b
there is some equilibrium as defined by
the chemical properties of a and b
such that the equilibrium lies far to
one side or the other
and that equilibrium is determined by
thermodynamics
it is not determined by enzymes
i don't care how much enzyme i add if
the thermody if the equilibrium lies
towards a
as i draw it the more i can add all the
enzyme i want
and i can never create more b
and so this is super important and is
actually a point
that has gotten wrong by lots of
biologists
they think oh this enzyme is expressed
therefore this pathway must be happening
or this reaction must be happening
faster
you need an enzyme to catalyze a
reaction so
a reaction may not occur your wood may
not burn unless you give it a spark a
catalyst to actually make it happen
but you cannot add a catalyst to fight
thermodynamics you cannot take that co2
in water and turn it back into a tree
and the same thing is true you can add
all the enzyme in the world you want
and all it will do is help a and b
establish the equilibrium
that is defined by the thermodynamics of
the relationship between
a and b now what determines the
equilibrium between any two species
that's a topic for another class why a
species is favored to be one side or
another
however a useful tool to think about
this in biochemistry
and quantify this for any pair of
reactions is something you've probably
learned about before it's something
called the gibbs free energy
gibbs free energy or
delta g delta g
is related to the way we'll talk about
the equilibrium
constant and it's basically a term that
we can use
to specify if a reaction is favorable
or not and so hopefully you learned
in an introductory class that if delta g
is less than zero our reaction
is
spontaneous if delta g
equals zero a reaction
is at equilibrium
if delta g is
greater than zero our reaction
is not
spontaneous right if we take our log
and ask what is delta g
to turn that log into co2 plus water it
is less than zero because it is very
spontaneous
if we take a pile of ashes and ask what
delta g is to recreate the log
it's greater than zero because it ain't
gonna happen
and if it's at some equilibrium delta g
is
equal to zero now
delta g depends entirely
on conditions all right as we will see
in a minute
and because of that this means
that there can be
conditions
where absolutely any reaction
can be favorable if the conditions are
right
and we'll see that this becomes very
relevant to understand how metabolism
works
and so let's go back and just now
consider
some generic reaction a and b
so at equilibrium what happens
so at equilibrium
the concentration of a and the
concentration of b
are not changing okay delta g
equals zero these two things are at
equilibrium whatever that equilibrium
is a and b are not changing in
concentration
now if i come and i add more a
to this side of the equation what does
that mean well you know from le
chatelier's principle
that that's going to favor production of
b we have
shifted things now out of equilibrium so
if i
add a
that leads the production
of b to re-establish this equilibrium
that means that delta g from
a to b is less than zero
until i've reestablished equilibrium and
now delta g is
back to zero again now what happens if i
add b
well if i had b now i'm going to produce
some a
all right so add b
okay that leads
the production of a until i reestablish
that equilibrium
all right so delta g in that case to go
from
b back to a the reverse reaction
is less than zero or i could also say
that delta g to go to a to b here
because that's not going to happen i
just added more b
i'm not going to suddenly create more a
more b from a
so here now delta g is greater
than zero all right now note
when i did this i don't actually have to
specify
how much a or how much b i've added
the equilibrium depends on
the ratio of b
to a okay not the absolute concentration
of either species and so having a way to
think about this equilibrium it turns
out
is also useful for biological systems to
define
some delta g that is
helpful to relate to this equilibrium
constant
and that is this concept
of delta g naught prime
a standard free energy which for
biological systems is
what the relates to the equilibrium
constant at 25 degrees with a ph of 7
and 1 atmosphere
pretty typical biological conditions and
this here is basically related to the
equilibrium constant
and we can calculate the actual delta g
by the following formula delta g equals
delta g naught prime
plus rt times the log
of the products over the reactants so
this would be drawn
for the reaction a to b
so the reaction a to b is related to
delta g not prime which is related to
the equilibrium constant i'll tell you
that how in a second
plus r is the gas constant t is the
temperature in kelvin
times the natural log of the ratio of
products
b over reactants a
all right this tells you whether or not
at specific concentrations of bna
that is a specific ratio of dna whether
it is favorable
to go from a to b delta g less than zero
or whether it is favorable go do from b
to a
delta g greater than zero and so
this should begin to make it clear that
whether or not a specific reaction
occurs
is affected by the actual conditions
present
and you can calculate that based on
this relationship and so if i specify
concentrations of a and b
as well as delta g not prime i can know
at those concentrations which direction
of the reaction
is favored now of course
my drawing a to b is entirely arbitrary
i could equally draw it b to a and if i
did that
okay so this is delta g not prime
a to b all i do is flip the signs so
delta g
equals delta g not prime
the negative of a to b
is equal to the positive of delta g
naught prime
from b to a okay because the direction
is arbitrary
plus rt log in this case now i have a
is my product and b is my reactant
if i just flip the sign flip the that
ratio is just going to change the sign
of my product and give me exactly the
same result with the opposite
sign which makes sense what's favorable
in one direction
is not favorable in the other direction
and vice versa
now i can also set delta g
equals zero that's equilibrium
if i do that then delta g naught
prime equals negative
rt so this would be for a to b
i'll use the top example so delta g
equals zero then i have delta g not
prime
equals rt times the log
b over a so if i know two things are at
equilibrium
i can calculate delta g naught prime
and know what the equilibrium constant
is
and so it follows from this then that if
delta g naught prime
is negative that means
b is favored over a
at equilibrium
okay and if delta g naught prime is
positive
that means a is favored over b
at equilibrium
all right and so delta g
naught prime really is a convenient way
to look at a reaction
and know which direction the equilibrium
rot lies
so a and b delta g not prime is negative
equilibrium lies to be
between a and b if if delta g not prime
is positive
the equilibrium lies towards a
but the key concept is is that for any
specific reaction any specific
conditions of a and b
whether or not a is converted to b will
be
defined by the equilibrium constant but
it will
also be defined about what delta g
is under those conditions
so to be clear
delta g will depend
on conditions
okay because i'll write it again delta g
equals delta g naught prime plus rt
times the log of
for the reaction a goes to b so products
over reactants and so
whether or not a is converted to b
will be a property of the equilibrium
constant
plus the concentration of b in the
concentration of a
that ratio of concentrations at the
conditions
present and if in that calculation
delta g is less than zero that reaction
is spontaneous
if delta g is greater than zero
that reaction is not
spontaneous or to put it another way
if delta g is less than zero under those
conditions
energy is
released or if delta g
is greater than zero that reaction will
not occur
without energy input
okay if i burn wood
energy is released but there's no way i
can reassemble that log
without some kind of energy
input and really getting this concept
is central to understanding metabolism
as well as what
biological energy means and hopefully
what is now apparent based on what i
just said
is that what
really determines delta g
is two things of course it's the
equilibrium constant
but in essence delta g for any reaction
is proportional to
the ratio of the reactants
over the products and that i can come up
at least in theory
with any relationship any ratio
of reactants to products to make this
favorable
at some tiny tiny concentration if i
have
nothing but co2 in water and infinite
time and infinite catalysis a tiny bit
of wood
could spontaneously form and so life
really creates the conditions that allow
that
and select for that to happen and of
course add energy input so it can
actually happen more
and so this should be very clear to you
that absolutely no
reaction is irreversible i don't care
what your textbook says
lots of sources will discuss
irreversible reactions i'll talk about
irreversible reactions later in the
course but what we mean when we say the
word irreversible
reaction is these are under conditions
that are found in
cells and in nature and i stress this
because if we want to understand the
energetics for how pathways work
we have to appreciate that
life can create conditions to do
unfavorable things because that's the
only way
the pathways can work
all right what do i mean by that well
suppose again we'll come back to our
reaction
a goes to b all right suppose
i need to build a pathway where i need
to convert a to b
because b is actually useful for some
purpose
that i need to do in a cell however
what if this is at least by equilibrium
unfavorable what if the equilibrium lies
towards a
that means delta g not prime
is positive is greater than zero
for a to b what does that mean delta g
not prime greater than zero for the
reaction a to b
that means the equilibrium lies towards
a and so there is no amount of enzyme i
can add
that will allow me to net convert a to b
because the equilibrium lies far towards
a
however whether or not a cell is able to
build a pathway where it converts a to b
depends on delta g not the equilibrium
constant for that
specific reaction so how can i turn a
into b well i could turn a into b
if i keep the concentration of b low
enough
that delta g not delta g not prime
that's the equilibrium constant but
delta g favors
a to b conversion that is delta g for a
to b
is less than zero how can i do that well
remember
delta g equals delta g not prime
plus rt log
of b over a all right
so this term is positive
because i told you the equilibrium lies
towards a
all right so i need a concentration
a ratio of b to a such that b
is low enough that this term
is more negative than that term
is positive and if that's the case delta
g will be less than zero and i can net
move that forward so how can i do that
how can i keep
the concentration of b low well i can
build a pathway
that consumes b in a way to keep it low
which favors a to b conversion in other
words i can build a pathway
a goes to b goes to c okay
so even here where delta g naught prime
is greater than zero
if delta g
naught prime for this reaction b
to a is much less than zero such that
equilibrium
strongly follow strongly favors c
that means my unfavorable equilibrium
here
can be overcome by the very favorable
equilibrium
of b to c in essence i can use b to c
to pull a to b such that it
actually happens produce this
intermediate that's useful on the path
to making c this strategy
is used in lots of metabolic pathways
and it's useful to generate lots
of chemically useful intermediates
now note that this only will work
if conversion of
a to c is favorable that is
if delta g not prime is
less than zero i can only pull this
reaction
if delta g not prime is less than zero
that is if equilibrium
favors a to c i can build a pathway this
way to do something
unfavorable on the way
to making c this brings up another
key point and that everything that we
discuss
relationship between any two metabolites
in
any single reaction
also must be true for entire pathways
so i have a three-step pathway from a to
c
whether i turn a into c in one step
or turn a into c in multiple steps
the free energy is exactly the same
if i burn wood by lighting it on fire
it releases the same amount of energy
then if a termite
has an enzyme that breaks that beta 1 4
linkage in the wood
and can burn that glucose stepwise
through metabolism
the exact same amount of energy is
released
glucose on one side co2 and water on the
other side
exactly the same amount of energy
released whether i do it in one step
or i do it in multiple steps the
equilibrium constant
between those has to be the same and the
delta g has to be the same
between all of it and so it should
become apparent then
that a to c has to be favorable if i'm
going
to use this trick of keeping product
low in order to pull an otherwise
unfavorable reaction forward
in other words there's no way for me to
keep b
low and net convert a to b
all on its own that will not work and
it's these
unfavorable reactions that ultimately
then require
energy input and this is where atp
now starts becoming useful for
cells
okay so now i want to talk a
little bit about how atp provides energy
that allows otherwise unfavorable
reactions
to occur and atp is useful
because delta g applies to
sets of reactions in the same way it
applies to single reactions that is
applies to whole systems all reactions
are a series of reactions
whether they happen alone or coupled
together
all have to follow the same rules
so now let's make our reaction more
complicated let's
say a plus b goes to c plus
d where this is really two reactions
coupled together
a being turned into c and b being turned
in
to d all right so will this reaction
happen can i turn a plus b
into c plus d well how do i know well
it's going to be
got to calculate delta g and so it's
going to be
delta g not prime for
a going to c plus
delta g not prime for
b going to d so those will relate to
what's the equilibrium constant the
equilibrium relationship between a and c
and b and d
okay if it's less than zero equilibrium
will favor to the right if it's greater
than zero equilibrium will favor to the
left of a and c and b and d
add them together that gives me my
overall
delta g not prime for those two
reactions plus
rt times the log of the products
so that's c and d
over a
and b products over the reactants
okay so if i take an
unfavorable reaction say a to c if delta
g naught prime is greater than zero
okay so would favor a and i couple it
to another reaction b to d that's very
favorable
because i add these two terms together
i can now take something that where the
equilibrium would be
unfavorable and make it favorable
however
whether or not this actually happens
still
depends on this ratio
of products to reactants so it still
depends on the ratio of c to a
and d to b
in our hypothetical thing here so to
know if a specific reaction will
actually occur
we have to take into account both the
sum of the delta g not primes related to
equilibrium constants
and the actual ratios that are present
in cells and so the net effect is
is that i can couple more favorable
reactions to make
otherwise unfavorable reactions now
become favorable
that is have energy input
but it still depends on conditions
and so let's think a little bit about
the polymer synthesis
that we learned from professor yaffi
and so in that process what did we do we
made several polymers and you learned
about the chemistry to do this we made
dna
we made rna and we made
protein these are polymers of nucleic
acids
protein is a polymer of amino acids
all of these fight entropy right we're
building polymers not breaking them down
and all of them were synthesized
using reactions that hydrolyze
atp in fact those reactions
actually hydrolyzed atp in the following
way
in every single one of those cases
if you look back
what you will see is that they all had
steps
where atp was taken to amp
plus two inorganic phosphates
this reaction is very favorable
in fact it's two reactions it's really
atp goes to
amp plus pyrophosphate
and then that pyrophosphate goes to two
inorganic phosphates it turns out
delta g not prime
is less than zero
for both of these reactions okay that
means the equilibrium
lies towards amp plus pyrophosphate and
here the equilibrium lies towards two
inorganic phosphates and so there's
actually two
tricks here by metabolism one is it's
two very favorable reactions that were
coupled to do something unfavorable
build a polymer and it used the trick of
keeping
pyrophosphate low by coupling it to a
downstream very favorable reaction
which even further pulls this reaction
and
is a way why you can actually get
good um why atp hydrolysis here becomes
so useful
as a way to build these polymers
let's just go quickly and add a few
numbers to show
exactly what i mean by how atp
hydrolysis
can be useful in this setting and so
let's do something a little simpler
let's go to atp
plus adp plus to inorganic phosphate
all right so let's give this some
numbers delta g not prime
in this case is equal to negative 7.5
k cals per mole all right
what does this mean delta g not prime
is related to the equilibrium constant
it's
less than zero which means the
equilibrium lies towards
adp plus phosphate okay
now let's see how this actually helps by
considering
what the first step in glucose
metabolism by
cells is so the first step cells do in
glucose metabolism is
add an inorganic phosphate group to
glucose
so it's this reaction glucose
plus inorganic phosphate
goes to glucose
phosphate just a quick note on shorthand
that i will use in this course
so pi of course is inorganic phosphate
that is this
po4 three minus
group all right when it forms a
phosphodiester bond
like to an alcohol in one of the glucose
molecules i'll draw this
in a future lecture i'll oftentimes
indicate it by putting a circle
around the phosphate and so adding this
phosphate to glucose
is a step that traps that glucose in
cells
for now let's just consider this
reaction and so
delta g naught prime of this reaction
is positive 3.3
k cals per mole what does that mean
delta g naught prime relates to the
equilibrium constant it says the
equilibrium constant lies here to the
left to the glucose
plus phosphate side so if we want to
net trap glucose phosphate
in cells well it's not going to happen
spontaneously
you need some kind of energy input that
can come from
atp and so if we couple
those two reactions as follows
so we now have glucose
plus atp goes to
glucose phosphate
plus adp
all right now let's draw this out what
is
will this happen so we can calculate
delta g
delta g equals delta g
not prime so there's two reactions
happening here glucose to glucose
phosphate and atp to adp
we know what delta g naught prime is by
adding those together
so it's 3.3 plus
negative 7.5 that equals
negative 4.2
what does that tell us that says now
we've created conditions where the
equilibrium constant
lies towards the right towards the
glucose phosphate plus
adp side but how much of this occurs or
whether it occurs
isn't just the property of the
equilibrium constant it's also how much
is there
and so that's rt times the log
of the products glucose phosphate
and adp
over glucose
and atp and so
if this term is less than
4.2 that is if the ratio of glucose
phosphate to glucose and adp to atp
in this term ends up being less than
positive 4.2
this reaction is spontaneous it is
favored
lots of conditions where that would be
the case although if this term is
4.2 or greater now it will no longer
occur
how much atp is needed well it's hard to
answer this question in absolute terms
because if there's a lot of adp around
you need a lot more atp for the adp to
be useful
and this is the problem with equating
atp with energy
the energy here is in the ratio of atp
to adp or atp to atp
and this is something that we will come
back to in the next lecture
because in the end this is what will
determine if a reaction is happens
it is not the absolute concentration of
atp
it's the fact that atp hydrolysis is
favorable
but how favorable that is depends
on the relevant concentrations of atp
or adp and relative concentrations
are all that matters in thermodynamics
it is
not absolute concentrations it is the
atp
adp ratio that is the correct way
to think about energy and this is true
for
any reaction with respect to energetics
if an atp adp ratio exists such that
when coupled to a reaction delta g is
less than zero
then it becomes spontaneous and this is
how
atp provides energy and we will come
back to this more
in the next lecture thank you
you